foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
are we online Tom
proper job I welcome the
members of this committee including the
new members and members of the public
who are watching on YouTube
we've got a relatively lighter gender
but it doesn't necessarily mean we can't
have some discussion
uh looking at the agenda we'll deal with
item one apologies for absence
yesterday I went apology councilor
um Piper councilor Wheatley substituting
thank you
item two is minutes of the community and
resources Committee of the 8th of March
that's the old Council
um
I trust you've all read them
are we happy with the content
so I think we have to take a formal vote
on this don't we
right all those in favor someone will
shout out can we have a proposal Council
James
seconded councilor Brenton
so we'll take them through
it's a straight vote not not
um recorded right okay those in favor
please show
one two three four
seven a six
those against
none
those abstaining
five
who were miscounted
nope
oh absolutely
yeah absent thank you
right
item three
action list
who's gonna take this one
yep Steve okay so there's only one item
on there that relates to the the skate
park
um and that during the last Council it
was agreed that the item remain on the
action list but there's nothing
currently required
fair enough counselor Haynes
at the Active travel meeting we
requested that so we should put a
proposed cycle route through Victoria
Park on CNR for September
it's wondering if we could go on the
list please
well well yeah Steve I'm sure they'll be
up later on the agenda when you come to
the forward plan thank you
right
counselor leather
thank you chair yeah just a question on
the skate park and I see councilor
Christie
raised this about the flooding issue
what is the issue with
possible flooding in the skateboard
we've got the Biddeford children's
center near the rugby ground and that's
in the same
risk area in fact when they're planning
application was applied for
the environment ages agency said it
shouldn't be built there but nonetheless
it went ahead councilor Christie
thank you yeah I raised this because
um if you've been in Bedford long enough
you would have seen the sports ground
underwater
and the skate Bar Park is right next to
it because but torridge were suggesting
as one of the um
one of the issues to address the noise
problem we're going to build a wall
right across and I was worried that
water would Pond up behind it next to
the houses and that's why I've asked
this I do understand however that I
don't think the complainant has come
back to torridge mainly because I think
they've moved
laughs
okay
I think we can move on item four public
contributions I've got none we've got
none that's easy
item five forward plan
yes sorry go back to what I said earlier
can I report that on September agenda
please
it's a proposed cycle route through
Victoria Park it's coming out the active
travel working Advisory Group
no problem with that but anybody object
or are we happy with it
or quiet
cancel the leather
well yes stick it on me on the forward
plan then for September but I can't see
that the public would be very happy if
we sanctioned cycling in the park
I just wonder what the idea is because
there is a new cycle we're going to come
down from Lima's Lane through the new
development there to choke them and then
along through the following the
riverbank and the riverbank car park and
I would have thought that was a sensible
route to have in the area
chair can I come back on that yeah is
that some considerable discussion of
that to travel there's two options one
through Along by Riverbank house through
the key
um the officers are very much against
that because
um it would conflict with parking
traffic on the key and the officers have
been very supportive in looking at a
possible route through Victoria Park
there are precedents in the rest of the
country in Balance Board as the route
through the park at pilton for instance
so it needs to come for discussion
really and to get resolved so I mean if
counselor leather wants to oppose it at
the discussion fine but it needs to be
discussed
definitely one for next CNR meeting
isn't it
counselor Christie
could I ask in the September meeting we
do have the Traveler's site put on here
because
I did raise this at planning that when
our local plan our joint local plan went
through last time the inspector pointed
out at the time that we did not have a
tolerated trespass site for travelers
but he allowed our plan to go through on
the understanding that we were going to
get one
if we present our new local plan
whatever that's finished
and we still haven't got a site I can't
see the inspector passing it he'll just
say well I'm sorry but you've just you
haven't done what you were told to last
time
um I have
for a long time now I've been suggesting
a site that we could use
it's on the link Road it's the abandoned
lay-by as you approach roundswell now I
understand that not long ago torridge
and North Devon because it is a joint
local plan and North Devon don't have a
tolerated site either that
Storage North Devon did actually
approach Devon County to buy it
but we were turned down for some reason
we really do need to get a grip on this
now especially after all the
fuss we had when The Travelers were here
you know last week and I think we really
do need to put this on our agenda and
rather than just kick it into the long
grass every time it needs to go on the
agenda I think Steve can probably give
you more of the background with them
County Council
um I guess it's what's what members want
to discuss to pray on the agenda because
we're just having a general conversation
around traveler's sites obviously uh
during the last two councils number of
sites have been brought forward to
members and they've all been turned down
for whatever reason or comment on any
particular reason we haven't made any
formal approach to the the County
Council they're just kind of General
discussion so there hasn't been a formal
approach made by both councils to Devon
County Council on any of their
particular land so I guess if it's on
the agenda what
is it that members want to consider
it certainly should go on the agenda
what councilor Christie says is right
from The Joint planning meetings
I recall that Devon County Council said
no they had alternative uses for it
um
we've never seen or heard about those
alternative uses are yes Steve actually
I believe they were the Link Road and
roundabout improvements
um but obviously they have been scaled
back in recent
recently
councilor Christie
yes we brought this up at the Town
Council and one of our we have two
counter councilors on the Town Council
who don't have any storage but one of
our County councils actually said Devon
County want to keep it for Road widening
do you think Road widening you're joking
I mean about 2050 maybe you know just
ridiculous
um but I wanted it on the agenda because
it will require some outlay of money
clearly and we are the finance committee
if you like and I think we need to have
it on because we need to get this going
if we're going to have a fairly quick
local plan a North Devon will have to
work with us because they haven't got a
site either
cancel another
yeah I didn't expect to be tripping in
so much at this meeting uh yeah I mean
I'd be happy if it is on the agenda it
needs to be
but those of us who are remembering I'm
sure councilor Christian Council Brenton
certainly will
when we did have the grant for that site
down just outside holdsworthy that got
turned down the money went back to the
government but at that time I and other
counselors were asking for the evidence
that there was a need in torrage for a
traveler's site
I've never seen that evidence because at
the time the evidence put forward was
in Tories really there's not that much
demand for a traveler's side North Devon
usually has far more Travelers in its
area than Torres do but I've never seen
any evidence that shows that we
definitely need and I suspect that's why
when the current plan went through the
inspector
Let It Go by I mean
we all know nobody wants a traveler's
site close to them do they that's a fact
they don't and yet traveler's sites have
to be accessible for the children on
those sites they both go to school for
services close by
and that's the conundrum that needs
solving but I'd like to see and Steve
the chief exec is asked
what we want on the agenda let's see
what evidence there is that we need one
here in storage
thank you fair enough I I think we'd all
like to see it on the agenda in actual
fact torridge did have a sight
and chose to sell it after it gave
itself permission for it
counselor lock yeah I'd remember that
application that holes were they and one
of the reasons it was turned down it was
too far for the Gypsy children to walk
to school
but eventually it did get clamming
didn't it
Steve
oh crap Peter can I just come back on
Council leather um he says there's no
need did he not notice the The Travelers
were here last week and created huge
fuss
um if we don't have a tolerated trespass
site we cannot move them on
I mean that's the need we have uh the
problem is that Devon County closed all
the lay bars where they used to go and
there's forced them into towns they
never used to come to Biddeford that's
why we need a tolerated dressed with
site because if we don't they will keep
coming here
I've got councilor Pennington as a
ordinary councilor yes
[Music]
that's police Powers not not District
Council powers and only in cases of
severe anti-social behavior and I I know
with these Travelers that were here
recently we had all sorts of reports on
very serious anti-social behavior and we
didn't have those reports and neither
did the police so I'm not saying there
was an anti-social Behavior but
directing that to The Travelers we
couldn't do to start off with secondly a
lot of the reports that were over
Facebook were not confirmed by Eva
Russell or the police and it is
extremely contentious you know to bring
the police down with Riot Vans Etc
is is difficult and they will only do
that if if it's severe
Behavior another on the next full
Council or gender is the protocol an
agreed protocol between us and the other
Devon authorities and the police and
that clearly sets out when they were
flat and when they won't act so in this
circumstances From toridge's perspective
the only thing we can do is go to court
and get a possession order to lawfully
and I mean lawfully
um so we have to go to court get a
possession order but we are in the hands
of the Court as to when that hearing
will take place
um
and like I said it was quite difficult
this time around because there was a lot
of
um comments and a lot of I mean I think
a lot of it was trialled by social media
when we were interviewing these people
and when the police are interviewing
um it wasn't as serious as as as as what
had been reported
um and I know we had reports to say that
the toilets had been destroyed the roof
had been ripped off the public toilets
none of that had happened we also had
reports to say the benches had been cut
up and burnt none of that had happened
and actually the site was fairly tidy
Steve uh thanks Jay just for another
Point um head of communities in place
just made a valid point to me
um obviously any site would need to come
through Community Resources committee
and I was probably on to follow Council
but in terms of determining the policy
content context and what's required
under local plans and local planning
legislation then it probably
ought to be the joint policy planning
committee that considers that wider
context in the first instance and
particularly if you're looking at
something joined with our neighbor in
Authority as it's a joint committee
looking at the Joint local plan then
that's probably the best place for it to
to start
accept that I well remember that
committee is hunted high and low for
sites in all shapes and forms
unsuccessfully
um I'm not averse to it coming to this
committee
so that we can really thrush it out but
um I suppose it actually needs a formal
vote to bring it to put it on the
forward plan doesn't it
we'll try that anyway I I would suggest
propose that we make a formal vote to
put it on the forward plan is there a
second to cancel the Christie
those in favor please show
11.
against
one
it will be on the jppc agenda and we
will be working with North Devon to
resolve it whilst we can have our own
ideas here it will be up to the jppc to
come to this Council and to CNR
initially and then to full council with
a proposal and what you're doing is
turning on his head a little bit but
there's no reason you don't discuss it
it's on the forward plan
it's on the forward plan yep
button can you speak take a vote on the
cycling is this just a technical matter
that you've just taken a vote on
on the Traveler's site or I think it was
agreed that the cycling goes onward it
was sort of tacit agreed
okay
anything else for forward plan
item six Declarations of Interest you're
all adults you all know that if you have
a pecuniary or a personal interest
you have to declare and you know the
routine
just to remind you
agreement of the agenda between Parts
one and two there's nothing proposed for
part two
but one we discuss finances always a
risk of needing to go into part two
urgent matters I have none
so we come to item nine decision taking
under urgency procedure
who's taking that one
Joe I can they say right so the
government provided extra financial
support for those in receipt of council
tax support and so an extra 25 pounds it
it was done under the urgency procedure
because we had to get it added on to
this financial year and the council tax
bills
I'm happy to take any questions but it
really is as simple as additional
financial support for those already in
receipt of council tax support
councilor lock can I just um asked at
the very City point but I'm still going
to mention it on page 13 where you've
got the signatures leader of council
stroke Deputy leader well I wouldn't
know whose signature that is so I would
and relating to the one below for future
reference for you know future councils
if they could print their names
afterwards because I wouldn't know it
was signed leader of the council or
Deputy leader from that signature
and I think they ought to print their
names afterwards that's the minor point
but I think it might be useful for the
future that's the fair point we can
arrange to do that in future cancer lock
yep it was Council Hicks and this
councilor Hicks and Steve Hurst those
signatures on there
I can confirm it is my signature
okay we can make the effort
s of June
um
and secondly for clarity
there's something about indeed property
which is the upper limit or character
types of course widely that's about two
thousand pounds a year to build it's
then 525 that the
faster day in the regression tax which
will protect us periods 50 times a month
but it's not 45 pounds for every month
or just wolves for the year
that's one of payment 25 pounds for the
year but but you what what you need to
remember with with this is most of them
are on council tax support or for this
scheme they're on council tax support
anyway so the actual amount that they
pay in council tax is either nil or very
minimal
um so 25 pounds is quite a significant
payment
even though they're all the highest
value
that that's separate so that's that's
the council tax discount
um this is council tax support so those
are macita council tax support which
they usually get alongside of a
qualifying benefits the actual amount of
council tax that they pay per month is
quite minimal
s
a year
it's one payment of 25 pounds
Steve
um I was probably just going to add a
bit to that perhaps I'll come to the
Pennington so for those members who
recall when David Hayes did a number of
budget sessions workshops and reports
um this was this money has been provided
as part of the cost of living crisis and
extra money from the government so if we
recall when we were looking at the
increases in council tax and the
increases in council tax for those
people in receipt of council tax benefit
it was Circa between 20 and 25 pounds
per year so this knocked that increase
out for that range of individual Council
taxpayers
yep
just to mention to
for counselor peninsula's benefit as
well I would always advise people who
are struggling to pay over 10 months to
go and pay their council tax over the 12
months
which they're entitled to do
right
we've finished with the urgency
procedure
move on to item 10 draft Financial
outturn
we have our new treasurer
thank you chair I'll take that one
um so this is a report on the draft
Financial outturn
um about the utilization of the
2022-23 Surplus
so this uh the utilization of this
Surplus is required to be confirmed by
CNR
so the draft Surplus for last Financial
year is can you speak up a little bit so
the draft um Surplus for last Financial
year is 853 000.
um now in the report this um states that
actually
we should note that this is after 374
000 from the transition in Government
funding reserve and repurposing of 553
000 of reserves so without the
utilization of those two we would have
actually had a 71 000 pound overspend
we've also had a one-off benefit of the
council tanics council tax Annex Grant
of 396 000.
um the report then has a table of um
where this
853 Surplus comes from the the main main
contributory factors
um so they are
mentioned some of the large ones so they
are adverse
um
adverse factor of 821 from temporary
accommodation and we've also had
inflationary pressures 453 000 staff
cost pressures largely from the pay
award also some business rates um timing
issues of 244 and then we've had some
more favorable variants variances which
is the
use of those reserves the 553 000 also
had increased income from short-term
treasury deposits due to the interest
rates the base rate Rising
the one-off council tax Annex grants and
then also various central government
additional burdens grants another 464
000 then some planning income
due to still having high levels of
planning vacancy savings exceed in our
budget and some extra income from the
boroughs
so that's where the Surplus um comes
from so then we have on the next page
the where it's proposed that we use this
Surplus so I'll just mention these
briefly so we've got 293 000 towards
temporary accommodation and Refugee
housing schemes and these are primarily
to be used as match funding towards um
two large grants one for five hundred
thousand which was initially for rough
sleepers and one for Ukraine
I think Ukraine Afghan housing scheme
000 they both require match funding from
torridge
then we've got 150 000 for
um
The Apprentice reserves succession
planning and practice reserves we've got
a hundred thousand for agency backfill
due to increased agency due to the
vacancy pressures we're under
we've also got 76 000 for a graduate
trainee which links in with a local
government Association a graduate
recruitment which we've um signed up to
we then have 50 000 for elections
um this is to top up the pot we've spent
143 000 on the last election and we've
currently just got 49 000 in the reserve
then there's 30 000 to support the plow
then 90 grand lease costs associated
with decant of operations from middle
dock
13 000 towards a future repair of the
pilot boat which is required to
refurbish every four to five years and
finally fifty one thousand uh
contribution to a Leisure reserve and
this matches the reduction in the
management fee we had with active torch
last year
um so that's that's the proposed
utilization
of the Surplus so the recommendation is
for our members to approve setting side
the draft Surplus from the 2023
2022-23 accounts as outlined in this
report
I'm happy to take any questions you may
have
yep counselor bright
what it meant
um
I was launched
some we get
no grants
and
to explain
the
um
I think that makes sense so we saw
there's some pooling
and then
scheme gets
coming from the
like
we hiding
yeah
Steve I treated that
covering two years so it's not just
how many covers all
costs of
the employer's contributions as well
um
we've been looking at what that
individual will do they're here for two
years
um will need to work with different
services and across different Services
over the course of that two years so it
refers to the the Apple door clear
Maritime Innovation Center they'll also
be working with us on leveling up
Partnerships working with Tom must be on
elections so covering a wide breadth of
things at a quite a senior level so not
apprentices
one of those
no answer
councilor Christie yeah thank you um I
noticed under the elections that the
cost has gone up because the voter ID
utterly pointless of course
um but could I ask we just had a
by-election in Northern I think torridge
Supply the offices and we do the sort of
mechanics we get that money back from
the parish don't we
and do we know how much it was
true comes to Christie is right in that
we recharge the the parish intern
Council
I think we finalized the costs
I'm following all the council Christie
I'd ring this on the spear here about
the elections and do we have to employ
an extra person at each polling booth
for example or is it
can we do we know is it an extras
all right
can't
cancel a bright
ER
foreign
it's the 293 000 central government
provided us funding for councils to
procure accommodation for refugees
should no refugees present within
torrage over what period of time is that
12 months or two years or
four years what period of time is that
the money can then be used
um
to fund our
God
and their homelessness
but I thought we'd subbed out this to an
agency the work with the refugees or am
I mixing up with the Asylum Seekers
which are separate from refugees I think
he Council level and it is very
confusing I I even I I I I think that
um so the h-a-f-1
um on page 24 that's for ukrainians and
afghanistans and the ukrainians we
already have a duty
um to house they can already be
presented as homelessness
for homelessness to the team and we have
50 free ukrainians um currently hosted
in torridge
under that scheme
um we're required to provide free
properties for unions and one for Afghan
families we don't currently have
afghanistani families
um in torridge you are very
um Pickwell assist us with supporting
those families
um but yeah the major plus to Torrid is
if it isn't used
um for Afghan or ukrainians we can use
it for our own temporary accommodation
I think the answer does that answer the
questions
is that over 12 month period or or is it
a longer period than that yeah they
haven't set a period actually so we've
logged with DCC who are responsible for
the Afghanistan's
um that that we will have one property
and we have no none currently in the
area
um so I don't know is the answer I
haven't been given um the guidance on
that but I I guess if they don't find a
match to the torridge area and to be
honest not many of them are that Keen on
being with in torridge because it's it's
remote and
a community here
and I have to seek further guidance I I
I I don't know is the answer
um
in the physics layers up the correctly
is because I assume in that side
properties to get to that figure
Wellness
try so
more than
under the rough sleepers 500
000 we're intending to provide eight
modular units
um but that the match funding required
is different for the the different
schemes so with the HAF one we're
required to much fund that by
um 60 percent
um with the rough sleepers we're
required to match fund by 50 percent
the 20 000 per property we get on top
um to assist with
um legal fees surveying fees
installation costs so that's not in
those those figures I think that's right
isn't it Peter so we're getting that
that on top so we'll get another 80 000
under the HAF one just for covering our
costs effectively
okay no one else oh came for the bright
foreign
specific uh posts
um they're kind of a best estimate we
currently have probably the most agency
staff we've had for a long time and we
recognize that there's an additional
cost to doing that so we've included a
figure of the best estimate based on
trying to split the the fun the money
that's available across these priority
areas and similarly with the The
Apprentice Reserve whilst we know how
many current apprentices we have the
council
the time
[Music]
yes
not off the top
ping it up because
it's in there
with
specific
exists
we
over a period
ship
agency one
entity
put yourself
managing the stuff
so we can monitor against it and
understand then if more or less is
required and then you can move it as as
necessary
foreign
these things
I just had a space on the best estimate
the numbers of Staff who have already
left
obviously you can't calculate when staff
might retire any longer because you can
work for as long as as long as you like
we've had a number of retirees recently
the age profile of our staff is top top
ended but as I said you can't guarantee
that people will will or will not retire
so it's as I said a best estimate staff
with the highest cost of running the
council by far and this record
recognizes the importance of having the
right staff in the right place to keep
Services running
if I do apologize I think I've been loud
enough
um it's okay for me to keep asking
questions on this issue can I carry on
sure
yeah okay good I will
um so
um
is uh what else we have the figure of 17
um staff turnover I think it was 17
staff turnover at the new member
induction and obviously we're putting
this money aside to to deal with the
fact that we're struggling to recruit
and senior members of Staff might be
leaving in the future
can you tell me any more about what else
is being done so if we're putting this
big big pot of money aside we're getting
in a we've got an apprentice we've got a
graduate trainee sorry we're doing the
commitments to the growing their own
we're obviously paying more agency staff
that's a lot of money to be assuming and
it's I mean compared to the staff the
variants that you had on the initial
table so we've had additional unexpected
staff costs mainly from the pay award as
you said but some Agency for 421 000
pounds so I get that they are really
really big costs but what else is is the
HR department doing
to try to counter this is 17 is that
what North Devon District Council is
saying a mid Devon District Council
saying
it's the same oh it's very similar
across across local government there's a
large uh proportion of Staff who are now
going into the agency market because
it's far more lucrative in terms of pay
we've had staff leave and leave just for
that that reason and want to come back
on an agency contract although obviously
we don't we don't operate that way so
it's a a problem right across the public
sector obviously it's different in can
be different in the private sector
because wages and wage levels can be
adjusted according to demand we've got
services that we have to continue
operating so for example our waste and
recycling services if we haven't got a
crew member on a morning when a round is
due to go out we have to pick up the
phone and get an agency member of Staff
we've had difficulty in recruiting to
the workshop and mechanics because the
salary levels in the private sector
between ten and fifteen thousand pound
higher than we're able to pay because
obviously if we did that for one member
of Staff it's uh
transposes across the entire Workforce
so we cut kind of quite restricted in in
that so it's a problem right across the
public sector whether it's in health the
NHS or local government everybody's
struggling with uh kind of that
recruitment in terms of what else the
department the HR department are doing
so we've
implemented a range of other health
well-being and kind of social type
things we've launched a new
website an app which allows members of
staff to access a variety of different
things support we've got a variety of
training so we've got quite a healthy
training budget to provide staff with
training obviously the the danger with
training is off to new train somebody
and then they they leave but we can put
things in place to call back training
fees and the like but if a new employer
offers to pay that and and pay more then
ultimately you get stuck so they are the
best estimates we have to enable us to
keep the workforce operating and keep
Services running
so that's one more question
um so the budget working group can you
move closer to sorry the budget working
group for the last Council they I think
it was that group that decided to cut
counselor grants in half so we now only
have a thousand pounds each as
councilors that we can give to local
causes in our community and those causes
I think are more more important than
ever because with regards to central
government funding for all sorts of
things our community is more and more
relying on a voluntary groups to
actually do things to make the town
better and that benefits toridge in in
you know different ways as well for
example Torrington and Bloom say their
charity organization they do things to
make the town centers tidy that then
we're not having to plant up every
border and every Park Etc so so things
so the charity sector does benefit us
and then we also help them with our
community grants so 36 000 pounds was
taken out of the budget so that we now
only have one thousand pounds each
rather than two thousand pounds as
counselors to support course in our
local community so that's 36 000 pounds
that's been lost in the budget and then
we're putting 250 000 pounds into this
kind of Staff cost this retention and
recruitment reserve and it's a it seems
like a lot of money to me and I just
want to feel that it has been properly
scrutinized could there be you know
we've we've cut a lot of funding from
the budget
um could we not have made could we not
put I don't know I can't do the maths
that quickly 214 000 pounds say rather
than 250 000 let's put 214 000 pounds
into those two we don't know much about
how much costs we're going to actually
need reserves and then reinstate the 36
000 pounds to make us have two thousand
pounds each of counselor grant funding
counselor James yeah well I think it
comes the bank for a long analysis of
the budget I would just like to come on
a couple of things quickly one is the
figures the three figures 150
176. I think what it illustrates is that
we've made a real conscious effort to
recruit graduates into the training
system and also to upgrade our staff and
encourage our staff to stay because we
are prepared to put time and money to
ensuring our staff are up together and
one of the problems we have faced is
we've lost staff in the past because the
offers they're getting elsewhere that is
the realistic situation we can't do
nothing about it it's the same all over
Devon that we're making a conscious
effort of how we deal with our staff
including the recreational side we do
the green room's been converted into a
restroom so they don't have to have
their lunch at their bench and things
like that and then the other one is to
do with I am the I was the chair of the
budget working group and we have to
balance the budget
and that within balance in the budget
there will always be unknown so it'll be
unknowns we don't know if as the saying
goes but we've balanced the budget we
we've got it through and yes we've we've
cut that but in actual fact the
members Council Grant always only used
to be a thousand pound and we did have a
surplus from the new homes bonus uh for
a couple of years which we don't get at
all no so we've lost what was a million
pound at one time the housing
um
yeah so we've lost that money so we have
to make that up and we can't give it
away if we haven't got it we have ring
and when we ring thanks the money for
the plow for instance the budget was
already balanced and by if we had just
given that money away we would have gone
into a negative situation so we have
worked hard or to be precise the um the
finance departments worked hard to
actually cut all the money together and
we don't know some some Mondays what
money the government's going to give us
on a Friday and we don't know by the
following Monday whether it's been
canceled again so you know
I I want to move this
um because I've got meetings the rest of
the day
um and I pretty support the report on
mine's locked up a minute now
um I need to get rid of it
um so the the recommendation is to
approve setting aside the draft Surplus
for 22-23 us outlined in the report I
move that report
I need the resolution
right let's see
Ken has moved the recommendation that we
received the report is there a second
there thank you counselor Whitaker
do you want to say any more on it Steve
I am chased any one point in in relation
to Council of Rights made it's the
member budget working group hasn't got
any decision making Powers it would make
made recommendations to full Council and
it was full Council it decided to move
or reduce the member grants not the not
the working group
okay we've got a recommendation to
accept that report proposed and seconded
can I have a show of hands those in
favor
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten against
abstaining two
thank you
now I believe that brings us to the end
of this meeting
um
a little bit longer than some were
batting on it's taking us 51 minutes
um
thank you for your attendance and
declare the meeting closed